justement de lui vous prenez de l'ombre
âge
ne savez vous pas bien pourquoi je le
ménage et que dans mon procès ainsi kim
a promis il peut intéresser tous ceux
qui la dame y perdez votre projet madame
avec constance et n'a ménagé pour leurs
rivales qui ont formé de tout l'univers
vous devenez janou c'est que tout
l'univers est bien reçu de vous c'est ce
qu'ils doivent asseoir votre avis
tranché puisque ma complaisance et
surtout s'est penché et vous auriez plus
lieu de vous enfoncer
si vous me la voyez sur un sel remet à
ses mémoires que vous blâmez de trop de
jalousie qu'elle te plus que tous madame
je vous prie le bonheur de savoir que
vous êtes aimée
lequel lieu de le croire à mon coeur
enflammé je pense qu ayant pris le soin
de vous le dire
un aveu de la sorte a de quoi vous
suffire mais qui menacera que dans le
même instant vous ne disiez peut-être
aux autres tout autant certes trois
mamans lafleur était mignonne et vous me
traitez l'a2 antilles personnes et bien
pour vous ôter nos semblables le souci
de tout ce que j'ai dit je me déguise
ici et rien ne serait plus vous tromper
que vous-même seriez content faut-il que
je vous ai version d'un duisans trope
vous êtes allé c'était une répétition a
précisé denis c'était une de toute
dernière répétition merci raison de voir
ce matin de venir vous êtes le coup de
coeur de jean louis david il avait envie
qu'on fasse un gros un gros coup de
projecteur sur vous ce n'est pas deux
années pas d'aujourd'hui j'ai vu de noni
plusieurs fois donc l'avant dernière
fois c'était la création admirable du
revizor salle richelieu de français
hélas au vieux colombier dans la mise en
scène de michael et avec petit de bayser
d acteur merveilleux comme par exemple
michel favory par exemple là on à trélat
il donne à un alceste qui est tout le
plaisir secret que certains grands
acteurs comme denis peuvent apporter au
public c'est à dire montrer aux gens
qu'on peut qu'on peut interpréter
molière comme on part dans la vie c'est
être dira qu'une souffrance simple avec
une humilité qui est pas simplement
l'humilité de l'acteur mais celle du
personnage c'est vraiment magnifique
denis vous aimeriez qu'ils écrivent pour
vous mais ça c'est gentil lors bien sûr
bien sûr ce que plus le même
jean-loup la fois où je l' ai découvert
je me souviens très bien justement
c'était à l'entracte du revizor les jo
dit tiens il ya jean loup dabadie et
puis je le vois venir vers moi comme ça
avec cette aménité de grands sourires et
vous rendez compte que c'était pour moi
fait également touché le lendemain
j'avais un message sur mon répondeur que
j'ai fait écouter réécouter à ma femme
elle est donc j'étais effectivement
profondément touché puis de son
assiduité de spectateurs aux français
aussi est extrêmement avec tout ce qui
fait et l'impression qu'il est très
souvent au théâtre il est très souvent
partout tout en y étant entièrement
souvent l'affût jean loup dabadie qui
commet souvent elle a fait à l'affût et
puis cette chose je pense que les gens
qu'il faut qu'ils font de la musique et
qui aiment la musique et 10ème en
écouter ils vont au concert est allé au
concert pour lens est notamment allé au
français aller dans d'autres théâtres
aussi mais dans la passion où je vis
donc des acteurs c'est merveilleux de
découvrir quelqu'un comme denis
podalydès et qui tombe d'ailleurs dès la
première fois que j'étais allé c'était
dans un spectacle à au vieux colombier
déjà c'était charmant poche et et tout
son entourage
je ne le connaissais pas vous avez va
jouer le réviseur qu'après on est en
train de s'écrire pour lui écrit
notamment pour donner trois que mckay
soit reçue
[Musique]